what's up guy we're on the podcast right
now nate's pissed you're not here
yeah how's it going yeah nate all right
yeah just make sure
you ask some questions who cares about
any of his things just we need to search
for nate
yeah we got him no it's gonna we'll get
a few of his fans
make sure he knows it doesn't matter you
know like it's not gonna we don't care
we're just using his name
yeah we're basically just having to hear
it because like that's our marketing
plan we had burr on
we had gaff again and now yeah and you
gotta have some girlfriends the
girlfriends are definitely gonna stick
around to look at chrissy d
yeah yeah if it's like oh you know how'd
the podcast go okay he could do plug
whatever he wants it doesn't we're gonna
cackle over we just need him for the
search
yeah well he's got two two show that
sold out shows the town hall he made
sure to let me know about those
that's what i'm saying well no i'm
saying the kids there's no denying the
kid sells tickets
kids [ __ ] selling tickets the kid
says we got to convert his fans i mean
you know
i mean the guy's you know flying into
surprise soldier i mean he's an
egomaniac nut job
yeah i mean like who does he think he is
just coming in i'm going to surprise
start it's like just text the guys your
friends that
you're not the pope who you surprised
[Laughter]
i've never seen a kid get so much more
handsome in the last five years i mean a
kid named is that he's a he's a
piece he's a good-looking kid and a
couple years ago i used to say he looked
like the most handsome kid with down
syndrome at a down syndrome school
he looked like the kid like all he
looked like he had down stronger
there
yeah no he does yeah he looks like he
looks like a good kid he looks like a
good kid he looks like a good kid you
see it like
in the lobby of a hilton and and when
you're checking out and you're like this
kid's
you know he's from he's from here and
he's here for a convention
i don't got to put my credit card down
for incidentals yeah it's all taken care
of
we really hope you enjoyed that episode
whatever it was about this is just a
stock thing that we're taping on to
every episode
so go make sure you rate review us
subscribe uh turn on your notifications
get jiggy with it
and go to patreon.comridgeboys where
things get really wild